rejoignez télé gaucho la seule télé
libre de france info en suisse est
passionné par les caméras c'est bon je
vous prends stage évite de 30 années
dans le gard départ est pas très
fréquent d'accord babbitt pas forcément
tout de suite avoue que tu vois jean
loup à la télé le cinéma c'est son truc
je cherche monsieur jean loup s'il vous
plaît je vais introduire qui ce film et
non très bien prendre la caméra
bonjour les maqams et qui sont en
vitrine mais ce que c'est des vrais je
ne vous connais pas vous filmez gens te
pose une question karen tardieu hommes
et aux sétois karine toi je marque on a
besoin de moi dans mes petits non ça se
fait pas quoi qu'est ce qu'il sait faire
rioux alors autant bausch bon allez on
va fêter l'arrivée de victor à gauche au
quand même demain qui venait avec moi
les jumelles accord de moi je peux pas
comment ce constat chez patrice et
gabriel vous qui choisissent s'est
acheté un ou télé gaucho engagée contre
ce pouvoir qui en prime les plus pauvres
mais y aura aussi l'insolence de la
rigolade
l'idée c'est d'être gentil maintenant
pour les knicks et après d'élèves
l'ordre au [ __ ] mais voilà on va
pirater chirac
mes chers compatriotes sally tête de cul
c'est nous
ok
j'adore faire des trucs avec vous et
bien nous on va libérer la france de
toutes ces chaînes de mer